salut nous sommes de retour dans mon
bureau toute la semaine dernière j'étais
pas à la maison donc je vous ai fait les
vidéos dans mon autre bureau mais là
c'est bon je suis de retour
rassurez-vous la bibliothèque n'a pas
bougé aujourd'hui j'ai utilisé le titre
très peu ta clique retenir les dates en
histoire parce que cette vidéo va parler
de comment retenir les dates en histoire
quoi j'en aurai marre qu'on dise que les
tic sont plus qu'à cliquer pour un oui
pour un non
oui c'est possible générique
reversât en quelques points très rapide
premiers points pour essayer de retenir
une date pour un événement historique
il faut penser à globaliser l'événement
prendre le temps de le remettre dans son
contexte au niveau national voire même
au niveau mondial et aussi en termes de
tueur et prenons la guerre de cent ans
1337 au regard de 100 ans est ce que
c'est un événement global is able oui
déjà ça s'appelle la guerre de cent ans
ça dure un petit peu plus de cent ans a
fini en 1453
mais surtout le premier job à faire
c'est de se rappeler un peu quel était
l'état de la france à ce moment là quoi
ressemblait la france quels sont les
enjeux de la guerre de cent ans est ce
que vous pouvez vous dire une petite
histoire un petit résumé qui vous remet
le contexte qu'est ce qui se passait en
europe
à cette époque là qu'est ce qui se
passait dans le monde à cette époque là
quels sont les autres événements
marquants ayant eu lieu durant la guerre
de cent ans
quand vous répondez à toutes ces
questions pour apprendre une date ça
vous permet d'avoir une image précise et
comme bien même vous pourriez oublié la
date précise vous pourriez toujours en
parler en remettant les événements dans
un contexte qui montre que vous avez
retenu la chose la plus essentielle à
savoir quand est-ce que ça se passe est
approximativement ensuite il existe
plein de technique pour pouvoir
apprendre à dire un petit peu à force de
répétition comme les flash cards vous
avez fait une vidéo là dessus je vous
invite à la regarder en cliquant ici
vous pouvez évidemment utiliser votre
table de rappel habituel si vous avez
déjà fait ce travail là on a vu ça toute
l'année ensemble mais sans aller jusqu'à
la table de rappel vous pouvez quand
même le faire un petit peu plus
simplement en créant une espèce de table
de rappel improvisé c'est à dire en
utilisant des images est une espèce
d'histoire que vous allez pas forcément
retenir précisément c'est pas là le but
le but c'est de créer des accroches
mental pour créer des sillons entre
chacun de vos neurones le cerveau aime
se souvenir des vrais souvenirs
justement de tout ce qui est
visualisable donc ça va améliorer ce
processus avec une logique intérieur qui
vous est propre et vous pouvez même
ajouter des rings là dessus
reprenons notre exemple de la guerre de
cent ans pour se souvenir de la fin
c'est quand la ville de bordeaux est
prise par le roi charles vii
ça se passe le 19 octobre 1453 alors je
vais vous expliquer maintenant comment
j'ai retenu le 19 octobre
1453 le 19 octobre c'est la date d'un
ami d'un de mes meilleurs amis donc là
j'avoue c'est facile j'ai juste pris mon
meilleur ami comme ça en exemple dans ma
tête je le visualise hockey et je
visualise en train d'arriver dans la
ville de bordeaux et 1453
je sais déjà que c'est dans l'époque de
1400 puisque je connais déjà la date de
départ dans les années 13 cents et que
c'est une guerre de 100 ans
eh bien sans me faire une image
particulière je me rappelle juste que ce
sont les des nombres qui suivent mes
mélanges et ils sont pas dans le bon
ordre par rapport à la guerre de cent
ans
sans je sais que c'est trois quatre cinq
mais il faut mélanger un petit peu tout
ça et comme au bout de cinq ans on
arrive dans les années 1400 et mais je
sais que c'est un 4 5 3 ça c'est
mélanger dit comme ça ça vous paraît
sûrement encore plus complexe mais c'est
que je n'ai pas fait un travail d'image
à retenir complet je cherche juste des
choses qui me parle des petites logique
pour pouvoir réactiver des chemins
mémorielle qui vont revenir plus
facilement que si j'ai essayé
d'apprendre la date par coeur parce
qu'également à chaque fois que je vais
essayer de me rappeler de cette date je
vais retrouver une certaine forme de
logique et ça va m'assurer que je suis
sur la bonne route
en terme de mémoire et le fait d'avoir
globalisé l'événement dans un
environnement et dans un contexte ça va
me permettre d'être sûrs que je suis
aussi dans les bonnes tranches d'année
en termes de siècle vous pouvez
également à prendre des petites phrases
très courtes comme dans la dernière
vidéo que je vous ai faite sur les
moyens de les mots techniques pour
retenir dix choses pour les présidents
français j'avais créé une phrase où
chaque première l'aide de premiers mots
correspondait un des présidents alors
que c'était plus un procédé
mnémotechnique dans les phrases pour
retenir les présidents américains mais
il existe un autre système dont je vous
avais parlé pour mémoriser pis pour ceux
qui veulent bien s'amuser cette semaine
on en crée une phrase où chaque mot
contient un nombre de lettres et ce
nombre de lettres une fois qu'on l'a
convertie en chiffres nous donnent une
donnée particulière ça pourrait très
bien être une date dans la phrase au
soleil fait roi je peux retrouver 1643
hausse et une lettre soleil cécile être
fait faillite et c4 est roi c'est 3643
et bien c'est l'année du sacre du roi
soleil
évidemment si vous allez faire un tour
dans ma playlist sur la mémoire vous
allez retrouver des informations sur le
my maps sur les tables de rappel sur le
palais mentale toutes ces techniques de
base sur la mémoire vous permettre
assurément de bien retenir des dames
mais si vous voulez pas fournir cet
effort complet pour retenir plus
facilement des dates juste simplement
que vous avez un contrôle à réaliser
quand vous voulez apprendre quelque
chose en termes de culture générale et
c'est utiliser juste ce que je viens de
vous expliquer aujourd'hui à savoir la
globalisation et des techniques qui vous
seront personnel en nombre de lettres en
astuce mnémotechnique ou alors en images
qui vous viennent comme ça ou en logique
perso pour pouvoir créer un chemin dans
votre mémoire un peu plus précis et un
peu moins abstrait merci beaucoup
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo j'espère que
ça vous aura plu ici c'est le cas vous
pouvez mettre un pouce en l'air c'est
toujours aussi important bienvenue sur
la chaîne si vous venez d'arriver via la
vidéo de pierre cros qui était assez
marrante puisque c'est la première vidéo
sur les 326 vidéo où j'ai eu un plantage
alors si vous voulez voir quand je
réussis à faire quelque chose vous
pouvez regarder dans les anciennes
vidéos par exemple de la playlist tour
de mentalisme et merci à vous tous les
abonnés qui est là depuis le départ ou
encore dan et au nez aujourd'hui le 22
novembre
on a passé la barre des cent soixante
quinze mille personnes qui suivent cette
chaîne merci à vous tous et comme les
vrais jusqu'au bout de la vidéo je vais
vous le dire c'est mon anniversaire
aujourd'hui et 175 mille abonnés c'est
un beau cadeau
merci beaucoup et rendez vous demain à
17 heures puisque le mental blog c'est
une vidéo par jour pendant un an du 1er
janvier au 31 décembre wade vous demain
oui
ciao
et